liebe zuschauer auch das muss man sein
jetzt gestatten sie mir bitte einen
kurzen moment der sentimentalität beim
fdp-parteitag in braunschweig am letzten
wochenende hat sich alexander gauland
vom parteivorsitz zurückgezogen
es war sehr emotional eine ja eine ära
endet hat zum glück bleibt der mann ja
ehrenvorsitzender und fraktionschef und
klimaexperte nur helgoland nur herr
gauland fragt was hier im land
eigentlich los wäre wenn kohlekraftwerke
lahm gelegt würden haben sie sich einmal
ausgemalt was ein tagelanger black aus
bedeuten würde
denken sie doch nur an die abertausenden
menschen die in fahrstühlen
eingeschlossen werden
man sich das mal aus sie lachen ich
hätte mir vor mit dem fahrstuhl
eingeschlossen
zu seinem nachfolger als co vorsitzender
wurde in braunschweig gewählt timo grub
aller besitzer eines malerbetriebs in
krauschwitz in sachsen ist dieser junge
mann und was er soll den osten in der
partei besser vertreten und er steht für
einen neuen stil rassismus und
ressentiments gern aber endlich schöner
verpackt mit überzeugenden inhalten
werden wir neue wählerschichten
erschließen
dazu braucht ist keine drastische
sprache und mit drastischer sprache
bedrückt man häufig das gegenteil vor
allem bei den frauen
schmerzvoll musste ich erfahren dass ein
harmloses bringen den müll runter du
[ __ ] bei frauen nur bedingt gut
ankommt ja sie hören der mann steht für
einen neuen trend die neue afd gibt sich
gemäßigt sie gibt sich ja greift muss
man so sagen dafür steht er ein team
okpala hat drastische sprache überhaupt
nicht nötig was weiß ich so klassische
nazi begriffe wie umvolkung diese
umvolkung verschwörungstheorie auf die
sich alle rechts terroristen der letzten
jahre berufen zu so einem quatsch würde
ein timo grub aller ganz klar sagen da
kann man in der tat auch von einer
gewissen umvolkung reden dieses wort
sollte man einfach auch mal benutzten
eben wo ja mal benutzen aber halt nicht
so drastisch wirklich unfassbar wie
viele medien auf diesen billigen pr trip
der partei diese woche reingefallen sind
dies war kein neuer rechtsruck beim
parteitag der vielen auch weiter recht
ist ja gar kein platz mehr
in deutschland leben genug leute die die
afd wählen wegen zitat jörg morton
gruppenbezogener menschenfeindlichkeit
also rassismus steht dazu statt euch zu
tarnen das ja fast schon
vollverschleierung was da passiert
doch gar nicht nötig wirklich habt ihr
nicht nötig alles nur aus bammel vor dem
verfassungsschutz deswegen reden sind
heute ist sogar von regierungsfähigkeit
widerlich wie die afg bei diesem
parteitag die arme cdu regelrecht
angebaggert hat hallo kleine cdu ist das
dein bald nur das heißt du dich mit zu
sehen
apropos bock auf koalieren baby ja wir
haben ein paar rechtsextreme nach und
die cdu hatte am anfang noch richtige
nazis und eigentlich wollen wir doch
dasselbe merkel muss weg also in zwei
jahren die beide harnik nackt in bonn
koalition
zwinker zwinker
[Musik]
ja
nach vielen dank auch jetzt bin ich teil
meine damen und herren
nicht nur ist der faschist bernd hocke
immer noch an bord in der afg sein
flügel zieht eindeutig die fäden aller
afd
die ihn mal kritisiert haben sind bei
diesem parteitag aus dem vorstand
rausgeflogen kurz gesagt die afg ist und
bleibt die same bewegung für rechte
mittel recht und richtig rechtsstreit
zweier welche irgendwann ist auch mal
gut ja schwimmen und tag mein name ist
ralf kabelka ich leite beim zdf in mainz
die neu gegründete abteilung für
entschuldigungen und gute beziehungen
zur fälschlicherweise als recht
diffamierten bürgerlichen parteien
seiten wofür dann bitte entschuldigen
einfach mal ruhe jetzt ja sonst ist der
zdf kantinen ausweis weg freund ja das
kann ich dir sagen sie haben ja nun
wirklich genug schaden angerichtet werke
wenn ich da an ihre grafik hitze der
letzten zeit denke hier zum beispiel
kliem rauen der rechtsradikalen test
geschmacklos
schneeflöckchen frauen mädchen egal ich
deutscher diese erfolgreich seit 1939
bitte sie also wirklich und jetzt stellt
sich heraus kfd ist total gemäßigt wie
stehen wir jetzt wissen sie mit ihrer
hetze show was sie da anrichten auch in
den afc familien hier zum beispiel ich
habe jetzt in der vorweihnachtszeit
meiner mutter die 800 kilometer entfernt
von mir wohnt ein bild von mir geschickt
in einem schönen weihnachtsbaum aber was
kam zurück von meiner mutter die nun mal
dauerhaft nur die regulären medien
anguckt mein sohn du siehst aus wie
hitler die eigene mutter sagt du siehst
aus wie hitler wissen viele ja nicht
hitler hatte furchtbare weihnachts
pullover ja die rentiere hatten als
beweise keine hakenkreuze aber sie jetzt
nicht der punkt wir als zdf müssen unser
verhältnis zur afg jetzt völlig neu
überdenken
wissen sie was passiert wenn die doch
mal regieren mit unserem geliebten
sender meine politische pflichtaufgabe
ist diesen wohl auch kaputt zu machen
dieses taj mahal einzureichen und eine
winzig kleine garage eine winzig kleine
öffentlich-rechtliche garage vielleicht
kommt eine hundehütte bewährten sehen
ein winzig kleines öffentliches gebäude
wieder herzustellen so klein so kleine
winzige hundehütte bleibt am ende übrig
wegen ihrer scharia scheiße wovon wollen
wir dann kiwi und dem fernsehgarten
bezahlen frage ich euch der ganze
sperrmüll von horst lichter bei baris
ferraris er passt überhaupt nicht rein
ins ohnehin gehört sein
sie entschuldigen sich sofort nein gut
dann mache ich das
im namen des zweiten deutschen
fernsehens erkläre ich die afg heute für
offiziell entnazifiziert außerdem ruft
das zdf folgende diffamierende
heute-show ausgaben mit afd witzen
zurück das betrifft die folgen 67 68 69
70 dann die wird mal 71 genau 72 74 und
wenn ich habe die 73 vergessen dass für
weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok
[Musik]
wo geht's denn hier raus
scheiße